-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Wow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That was great.
I'd like to start by wishing
everybody a happy New Year.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Happy New Year.
I can already tell 2022
is gonna be better than 2021,
mostly because it's impossible
for it to not be.
[ Cheers and applause ]
According to a new poll,
Americans say the one word
that best describes their mood
about 2022 is "hopeful."
-Yeah!
-Then 2021 heard that and was
like, "Yeah,
good luck with that."
[ Imitates puffing
on cigarette ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's amazing
how much life has changed.
In just two years,
our resolutions went from
"run a marathon" to "only spend
four hours a day on TikTok."
[ Laughter ]
That's your...
This year, my New Year's
resolution is to have
more self-confidence, but I just
know I'll screw it up somehow.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I like having New Year's
resolutions because you can just
make them up as you go, sort of
like the CDC rules on COVID.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Five days, four days,
three days...
Speaking of New Year's,
I saw that Jeff Bezos celebrated
at a '70s-themed disco party,
and he definitely
dressed the part.
Here's a photo.
[ Laughter ]
Look at those pants!
As they say over at Amazon,
that's a tight package.
-Oy!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Whoa-ho.
-Well, today President Biden
flew into Washington, D.C.,
from Delaware,
right as a major snowstorm
was hitting,
and when he landed, he actually
got stuck on Air Force One
'cause they had trouble driving
the stairs over to the plane.
Check this out.
-Ooh, come on.
[ Grunts ]
Mm, mm.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Whew, man, we were this close
to seeing the president
of the United States
jump down an inflatable slide.
[ Laughter ]
That would have been so --
This close.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we see that again?
I'd like to look at
the video again because I love
the two guys off to the side,
watching.
[ Laughter ]
Standing there, watching,
pushing a giant stair.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, good job.
You're doing a good job.
Good work."
Thankfully, Biden finally did
make it off the plane.
Here he is walking out.
Yeah.
That's right.
The last time D.C. was hit
with that much whiteness,
it was January 6th.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
[ Applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Coming in hot!
Coming back hot!
With the retweetable jokes.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, there hasn't been
that much white powder
since Jeff Bezos's
New Year's party.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on.
[ Chuckles ]
If you're keeping track,
Biden can somehow walk down
a flight of icy stairs
in the snow
but not up a flight of stairs
when it's nice out.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Oh!
-Oh, boy!
[ Laughter ]
The third one is the one
that gets you, yeah.
Some more travel problems.
This weekend, over 5,000 flights
were cancelled,
largely due to COVID.
Yep, airlines are having a tough
time staffing their flights.
You can tell.
Just listen to this
captain's announcement I heard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Rolling the dice --
Wow. Interesting.
-Wow.
[ Laughing ]
-Now, speaking of COVID,
the CDC recently issued
a warning to avoid cruise ships,
regardless
of vaccination status.
I'm sorry,
that was news from 2018.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, on the other hand, though,
you book a one-week cruise
and test positive, you got
yourself a three-week cruise.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Think about it.
You got to do the math.
Meanwhile, the CDC has cut
their recommended
isolation time in half,
and now it says you only need
to quarantine for five days.
Yeah, a lot of COVID regulations
keep changing
the longer the pandemic goes on.
For example, back then,
doctors said
to cough directly
into your elbow.
Now doctors say,
"Just have fun out there."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I don't know what that means.
[ Applause ]
Here's another example.
Then, the CDC said to avoid
large indoor gatherings.
Now the CDC says
parties are fine so long as you
set up a smaller,
"tested positive" table.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, back then,
you had to wash your hands
for as long as it takes to sing
"Happy Birthday" twice.
But now you can sing it at the
speed Applebee's employees do
when you can tell
they're not really into it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Happy birthday,
happy birthday ♪
♪ I brought bread,
here whatever ♪
And finally, back then,
they said to avoid
misinformation by staying off
the Internet,
but now the Internet
is where you live now.
It is your home.
[ Laughter ]
That's interesting.
A lot has changed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Well, some news from overseas.
Yesterday, South Korea said that
an unidentified person crossed
the border into North Korea.
Really?
[ Laughter ]
It's like running
out of Disneyland
and into...North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
I can't think of anything worse.
Well, everyone
is talking about this.
In the middle of the
Jets/Buccaneers game yesterday,
Tampa Bay wide receiver
Antonio --
You knew I had to talk about it.
[ Laughter ]
Antonio Brown got a little upset
and decided to leave the game.
Take a look at this.
-Antonio Brown boiled over.
Very upset on the sidelines.
Took off his shoulder pads.
He tossed his shoulder pads,
stripped off his shirt
and glove,
threw those into the crowd,
then ran across the field
while the teams
were still on the field,
giving the crowd
a peace-out sign.
[ Laughter ]
-Before you judge him,
that's the same way
Andy Cohen
left Times Square on Saturday.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh!
-Andy was great.
-Oh, boy.
-I have a feeling,
after one more variant,
that's exactly how Dr. Fauci
is gonna say goodbye.
He's gonna be like, "I'm out!"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a woman chose to quarantine
in an airplane bathroom
for three hours
after she tested positive
for COVID mid-flight.
It wasn't really a tough choice.
It was either that
or the overhead bin.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, a second passenger
spent three hours
in the other bathroom
after testing positive
for the hummus wrap.
-Happy New Year, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is Monday.
We're so excited to be back!
And we're kicking off 2022
with a great week of shows.
Cate Blanchett will be here.
Kenan Thompson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Milo Ventimiglia.
And the co-hosts of "Queer Eye"
will all be joining us
this week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
He stars in the series
"Black-ish."
The final season premieres --
I know, we love him.
The final season premieres
tomorrow night, on ABC.
The very funny Anthony Anderson
is here tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Plus, you can see him
in the HBO series
"The Righteous Gemstones."
Adam Devine is joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adam's very funny.
And we've got great music,
great, great music
from Carly Pearce, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Carly Pearce.
I hope everyone
had a good break.
We were off for two weeks,
and we double taped on Thursday,
and we had Friday off.
On Saturday, I was gonna come in
and do a bit
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Yep.
-And I tested positive.
But I was so scared,
because I went in --
You know, I normally come in.
I've been here --
We've been doing this testing
for over a year now maybe.
So I know everyone up there,
all the nurses and doctors
and everyone.
So I'm standing there
with the security guard
and some producers
for "Saturday Night Live"
and my assistant,
and the nurse comes back in.
She goes, "Come with me."
[ Laughter ]
I've never gotten --
I know, I've never gotten,
"Come with me."
[ Laughter ]
"Come with me"?
I go, "Wow.
You gotta be kidding me.
I mean, we test every day here."
-Yeah.
-And I wash my hands,
I do everything, I wear a mask.
Anyways, they put me in a --
like, a waiting area.
And it's like a glass --
a glass office, maybe?
-Yeah.
-It's a tiny desk and a phone,
and you're in --
and they shut me in there.
And they said,
"Someone's gonna call you."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
And they left, and I said,
"Oh, man, this is bizarre.
This is sad."
So I texted my assistant
and said,
"Please take a photo of me
in this room."
[ Laughter ]
And so this is me,
and this is true --
this is really me in the waiting
area, if you can see this.
That's me there.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. So, wait.
So this is --
So this is real deal.
I'm not even joking.
That's where they put you.
You know that room?
-I hang in there all the time.
-No, that's the COVID room.
You can't hang out there.
-I didn't know that.
-We've hung out there before.
-Yes.
-So they put me in this room,
right?
So every office has
a catch phrase from an NBC show,
like from "Cheers" or something,
or "Here's Johnny."
I'm not kidding.
The room I'm in is the
"What'chu talking 'bout,
Willis" room.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I zoomed in.
I zoomed in so you can see that.
I can't --
[ Laughter ]
That's where I found out --
that's where I found out
that I had COVID.
Yeah, that was the room.
That was the place
where I found out.
You can't write this,
you can't make it up.
-You were only there for like
an hour and a half, right?
-That's all, yeah.
So then, I call my wife.
You know, I go --
you know, we had to isolate,
and it's right before Christmas.
I go,
"Man, this is gonna be crazy.
What am I gonna do?"
So --
You know, but --
So they went Upstate
with the girls, you know,
and I just kind of sat there,
just isolated.
You know, I just did what --
You know, just --
You know, I just ordered
delivery, they dropped it
outside the door.
You know, whatever.
And then I said,
"You should have
the girls tested,
and you guys should test again,"
and they tested --
My girls tested positive,
as well.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And they're fine.
Everyone's fine.
They had the sniffles.
Frannie had sniffles
for like two days.
Winnie had no symptoms at all.
But that meant I could go home.
And spend the holidays
with the kids, so I did.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It was a Christmas miracle.
But anyways, it was --
I want to just tell everyone,
please, out there,
get vaxxed, if you can.
Get vaxxed, get boosted,
because, man, this thing,
it's a banger.
It's a real thing.
If I didn't have that, I know,
it just felt like I would be
real, real, real, real, sick.
So I want to thank
all of my doctors
for giving me the vax
and the boosters
and all of the nurses
and doctors that are working
so hard out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much.
I mean, you saved my Christmas.